my name is Billy toes and it's French my
mother's Martinez I'm a French Spanish
heritage primarily and I'm from a little
place called thibodaux in Louisiana
served in the state legislature and in
the Congress for 25 years actually in
Congress and I'm now the CEO and
president of the pharmaceutical research
and manufacturers of America otherwise
known as farmer here in Washington the
trade association that represents about
34 the largest global pharmaceutical
industry in here here in America I grew
up in the country a little place called
check Bay which wasn't it's even smaller
than Thibodeau if you can imagine so
going to thibodaux was like going to a
big city and I was sort of a you know
country boy look down on my big boys
from the city that grew up poor dad
never earned I think about poverty but
we lived on a farm and we you know we
literally grew up raising crops and
hunting animals and catching fish and
surviving I remember coming home in the
afternoon I'd say mom what's for supper
asia's I don't know go get something you
know and we don't remember being poor we
were always very happy and very well
taken care of but but looking back on I
realized we you know we were poor
country kids and so everything from
there was an adventure and I'm going to
go into high school and you know reading
Shakespeare learning you know history
and literature and science was a great
adventure for me knowledge and was it
was it was fun I was able to attend
Nicholls State University which is a
hometown university they have a part of
the junior college system initially of
ana state-run University I'd been
elected president my student body at
till too high and and so I got into
school politics and Nichols as well but
again it was a member those days is
really adventurous learning how big and
wide the world was and how much there
was to see and know and and do my senior
year in and Nichols had a professor who
had go coma and had trouble with his
eyes and he commissioned me to drive him
across America into Canada one summer I
spent the whole summer driving him
around and visiting all the universities
of the eastern side of our country all
the way starting with Fayetteville the
University of Arkansas going up into
Canada and Stratford watching a
Shakespearean festival there and going
on to keep back and then coming down
eastern seaboard visiting every one of
our great American universities I
remember that as as I opening and that
same year I helped the state senator get
elected and and and that opened up all
sorts of opportunities for me
hey